get it together man okay so the story's
hit about two hours ago they took mostly
tablets laptops and cameras sorry I'd
like a list of all your employees who
ever had access to the store I'd also
like to apologize for my partner his
parents didn't give him enough attention
detective I already solved the case
we're looking for three white males one
of whom has sleeve tats on both arms and
how do you know that I had an informant
on the inside
he's been here for years watching
learning waiting his codename
[Music]
fuzzy cuddle bear
he's a nanny cam ah you got lucky no I
got here five minutes before you and
figured that in this gigantic
electronics store there had to be at
least one working camera
oh hi bad guys you did it fuzzy you
busted him it's time to come home I'm
not sure if I can I've been undercover
so long I forgot Who I am I have seen
terrible things I haven't known the
touch of a woman in many moons detective
Santiago don't walk away from me I'm not
gonna torture this kid nobody said
torture why don't you let me take a run
at him boss in order to think like one
of these guys you have to think like
them greg pikitis would you like some
boiling hot coffee please
my name is Burt Macklin
I'm with the FBI huh looks like Andy's
wearing him down I'm gonna go finish him
off just shut up for a second he's a
jerk he has been such a jerk to see you
you would be are you crying I'm not
crying okay little urging to jerks okay
hi I'm Leslie Knope this is officer
Sanderson Bert Macklin FBI how do you
think you're doing you can't just hold
sixteen year old kid against his will we
were trying to question him about this
vandalism do you have any evidence yes
no two words no we H pit peach pit his
DNA is all over it I assume we don't
know that we can get it tested and if it
matches your DNA then you're going away
for a long time is this a joke no I'm
calling your shift commander Monday
morning I am calling your boss I don't
know who to call about you the President
of the United States of America fine the
mugeez working find a cabbage street
they began to over two months ago just
like this briefing did please go to
charisma class I'm here I'm here
sorry Charles no Jake never apologize
for making an amazing entrance my power
went out last night and my alarm didn't
go off your alarm is power dependent you
brought this on yourself son point is it
will not happen again
carry on sorry I'm late sorry it's no
hot water this morning but I'm here
ready to go will cause no further
distractions sorry sorry sorry
seriously what is your Excuse today more
bad luck
my car ran out of gas and then my
clothes disappeared from the laundromat
I had to beg one of my neighbors to loan
me some of his never told us Sinbad
lives in your building if Sinbad lived
in my building I would have a tattoo on
my forehead that says Sinbad lives in my
building I'm here I'm here I'm here and
I'm a half an hour early that's right my
string of bad luck has finally come to
an end
Peralta you failed your drug test there
were traces of cocaine and
methamphetamines found in your urine
what I've been staring at this board for
days so close to putting it together
there's gotta be something we missed
let's go over this again the video shows
that the pie came from a high angle so
it wouldn't hit your face like this
mm-hmm
don't close your eyes
no no it actually was from up higher is
that about right
yeah good clean yourself up let's do
this again alright let's go to the video
again sweet chick
Leslie exits the building and then you
get hit what else do we know we know
that Leslie was about 15 feet in front
of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim or Leslie wasn't the target
well hold on okay this permanent marker
go find Ben get a list of everyone he's
ever fired go go you son of a [ __ ] we
go take another crack at Whitman keep it
in there like five times what do you do
annoy him into talking haha two or three
four
[Applause]
didn't work queue the network
do you think I haven't been around the
world you've been everywhere darling I'm
a very wealthy woman my husband's kept
me in the finest clothes from Bergdorf
Goodman's freeze FBI kill anybody and I
didn't burn down the middle either my
sister no but now she can eat my walls
nothing to see here planning your
strategy no I'm just making funny faces
at him
this mirrored glass is awesome it's
straight-up works an effective you so be
a limited time it is actually that's how
I got him last time let him stew for a
little bit got in his head and he
confessed you better be right
I am hey make some funny faces while I'm
in there I wanna see if I can tell
I didn't do anything joke that's fine
you said the exact same thing last time
and have that work out for you let's
take a look you see with your trial you
in prison me meeting Regis Philbin that
was fun
you still in prison me at Splash
Mountain just pepper these in here you
in prison you in prison you in prison
you get it you got the wrong guy all
right all right I confess fine by me
I got all the time in the world no you
actually have 48 hours I know the law no
the doctor says it's probably not
serious but it might be no Kyle please
start talking why isn't it Burt Macklin
what are you doing here and who is this
sorry Charlie I'm Janet snake-hole I
demand answers let me know please I love
you no offense but Burt Macklin
died last night after the 10th shot of
snakejuice okay sorry
mrs. sinkhole you think I'd let you get
away that easily
bert macklin may be dead but I'm his
brother Kip Hackman why wouldn't you
have his same last name shut up Kyle I
know you boosted those paintings maybe
it was me but I'll never tell you where
they are and you'll never have my body
either heads up
there's our perp looking all her pee
just perp in his way down perp street
take a picture get one second miss
lights were really unflattering for his
complexion it doesn't have to be perfect
Tom Olsen is a bad dude he's held up for
electronic stores at gunpoint and I wish
you hadn't read that Annie Leibowitz
book we're calling it a book there's a
visual journey you're probably that guy
should shoot this in common set up like
a light yes shoot color why have you
been shooting black and white where's he
going now what
damnit NYPD break
[Music]
you strapped
our foot chase my birthday wish finally
came true
Oh God hey this how about stupid
terrible people
I need that birth certificate Leslie
wait here bert macklin is on the case
Andy no don't worry I can do this
believe me
spell your last name for me I also got
this dude's briefcases just laying there
kind of a panic move I believed in you
but you should put that back okay
I've been chasing this guy for three
months I've got him dead to rights
fingerprints witnesses it's in the bag
so I'm just gonna grab a healthy
breakfast of those gummy bears wrapped
in a fruit roll-up breakfast burrito but
yeah I pity your dentist
you